we may be nearing an answer tonight
about what happened to a Saudi
journalist who disappeared after going
to the Saudi counts consulate in
Istanbul Turkey sources now say the
Saudis will eventually admit that Jamal
Khashoggi may have been killed
accidentally during an interrogation
that news comes shortly after President
Trump sent his top diplomat to the
kingdom and as Turkish and Saudi
investigators conduct a joint inspection
of that consulate
we have Fox team coverage tonight John
Roberts at the White House tell us what
he's hearing there we start off though
with correspondent benjamin hall in
istanbul tonight good evening Benjamin
good evening Brett well if these reports
are true it would blow this case wide
open
after almost two weeks of strenuous
denials when almost all the evidence
pointed at Saudi Arabia well if this
report is true it means they will
finally admit being involved in the
murder
13 days after Jamal khashoggi
disappeared and Saudi Arabia has started
to cooperate on Monday King Salman
ordered an investigation into the case
headed up by the lead Saudi prosecutor
working in tandem with Turkey Turkish
authorities have been requesting access
to the consulate
since khashoggi went missing finally
today it happened four days now Turkish
authorities have been trying to get
inside the Saudi consulate to find out
what happened to Jamarcus shoghi they
are now just arriving Saudi and Turkish
investigators hopefully they can get to
the bottom of this saga investigators
spent at least five hours at the
consulate a Saudi team and Turkish
forensic police notably a cleaning crew
also arrived hours ahead of them both
now the European Union is also looking
for answers I think they're completely
on the same page with our American
friends on this we expect transparency
and we wait for having more clarity on
what happens on that case that is
particularly dramatic one on Sunday
Riyadh reacted angrily to political and
economic threats over the case saying
the kingdom of firms its total rejection
of any threats and attempts to undermine
it if it receives any action it will
respond with greater action Saudi state
media then suggested a hike in oil
prices to $100 if not two hundred
dollars about in another development
kinks
president Erdogan of Turkey spoke by
telephone Sunday evening with both
attempting to calm the situation I said
they would huddle main if the King
reiterated his country's keenness to
maintain the relationship with Turkey
the same way it is and that no one will
ruin that relationship pressure on the
Saudis mounts as more leading business
figures say they will not attend a major
investment conference in Riyadh later
this month the CEO of uber Richard
Branson head of the World Bank and the
head of JP Morgan among a few to cancel
its another major blow to the Saudis but
that major new report breaking tonight
the potentially Saudi Arabia preparing
to accept responsibility in the murder
is what's shocking everyone today what
consequences that has for Saudi Arabia
however remains to be seen Brett
Benjamin Hall in Turkey tonight Benjamin
thank you